first of all congratulations to you in
the entire group this is really exciting
and I guess they couldn't be here
tonight you're the only one here yeah
all the sketches on the show our film
remote so today those guys are off in
Jersey filming one of the various
sketches that will be seen over the
season yeah well this is really exciting
yeah awesome you know you guys it's a
very it's a very funny show and you guys
do great stuff I've seen you perform on
stage thank you guys do a great job
what's the group dynamic like do you
guys you know what actually if you don't
mind I'd rather use this time to talk
about something else is that all right
all right well yeah I know I mean I
thought you'd want to you know plug your
show but it's it's your time so talk
about whatever you want well actually I
kind of wanted to talk about a kind of
prejudice that never gets dealt with in
this country I'm talking of course about
prejudice against astronauts if the good
Lord walk on the moon then we wouldn't
be Morrissey me wait all right look I'm
I'm sorry that happened that yeah it's
okay okay so are are these the kind of
issues that that you're gonna be dealing
with on your show actually it is
[Music]
night it's weird I had no idea that that
this was such a touchy subject oh it is
and actually Comedy Central wasn't gonna
air the episode driving their moon Hey
look you know this is not Jerry Springer
okay
you know I know that you get you people
feel strongly about this but maybe you
can discuss it amongst yourselves after
the show okay
now actually Conan this is fine because
I had a pretty good idea something like
this might happen the only way to
confront these ignorant stereotypes is
to introduce these people to a real live
American astronaut if you don't mind
ladies and gentlemen lieutenant Mike
Birchwood American Hero
[Applause]
look just because I spent some time I
said here's gravitational pull doesn't
mean that I've changed that I'm
different than you that's not true
I drink tang because I like the taste
you have to taste a recycled urine that
is completely insane I have I have only
eaten breakfast upside down two or three
times since I got back from my last
mission there covered in a stroke germs
folks just last year an astronaut moved
into our neighborhood simultaneously all
the leaves started dying and falling off
our oak trees let me ask you let me ask
you a question sir what's that month
October September October
yeah it's called fall it happens every
year now sit down
mic Birchwood mic pls mic Birchwood is a
man like like you and I a man who'd like
nothing more than to settle down meet a
nice girl raise a family or the problem
is most women are afraid to touch me
they think I'm radioactive that's right
ladies
he'd make you infertile on a cap his
sperm from another time continuum
that's ridiculous I will not fornicate
with you with your juicy astronaut lips
and your astronaut buttocks I think
there are several issues going on here I
would gladly trade all of my walks on
the moon for the simple caress of a
woman who's begging you
what the hell is that moon cheese baby
little boy I mean he's probably
referring to how the moon's supposed to
be made of cheese but yeah but still I'm
the baby end up being made out of cheese
oh please
ignorant people make giant leaps here
that's all that's going on I'll tell you
what what would it take for you two to
finally believe that this astronaut yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
stop it enough
give me that cheeseburger you're trying
to incite a riot
I suggest next time you think of a
simpler chance pickles to me Mike I
apologize but would you indulge these
two buffoons and would you eat a
cheeseburger fine I'll just need a
blender what why would you need a
blender it was just a humor joke you
mean joke well I guess he is a real
American huh
protected by the Constitution of the
United States to live his life freely
huh feel a little stupid hey Mike Mike
chew your food Mike Mike Mike
[Applause]
kill me kill me before I become one of
them with the gun god bless you redneck
I can't believe I was shot right before
our sketch show upright citizens brigade
premieres next Wednesday August 19th
cent thirties Eastern Time a County
Central right up to South Park we also
have a website
www-wait Citizens Brigade calm and we
sell t-shirts they're only ten bucks I'm
dying
we're gonna take a break everybody when
we come back The Upright Citizens
Brigade will be here to say good